good afternoon everyone
thank you all for coming uh my name is
fenjin
and my colleague sitting in the front
row over there is gian
and both gian and i are software
engineers
from a san francisco data startup called
metamarkets
today we wanted to talk to you guys
about this idea
of building a real-time analytics data
stack
using existing open source technologies
and
specifically we're going to be talking a
little bit about
kafka hadoop storm and druid
this talk is really based off of our
experiences from building out a
real-time analytics data stack
at metamarkets and we use it primarily
for
online advertising data but we want to
talk about the general problem
of working with event data and then
we're going to talk
about how we gradually introduce
different technologies
to solve some of the problems involved
with working with this type of data
we're to go into the architecture of the
stack that we ended up with
what that looks like and ultimately how
you can go about
with getting the stack and trying out
for yourself at home
so to start off with the problem what
we're all trying to build
is we're trying to build applications
and these applications allow us to
arbitrarily
and interactively explore time series
data
now for us we work primarily with our
online advertising data
but some of the different applications
that we've seen some of the different
data stacks that we've seen
built that are very similar to ours
those stacks use
system and application metrics data they
use
network traffic monitoring data or like
website and activity stream monitoring
data
so time series data is pretty prevalent
now with the applications that we're
trying to build
there's several general problems that we
need to solve
for us in particular we care a lot about
multi-tenancy
so potentially many many users using the
system at the same time
issuing a bunch of concurrent queries we
obviously care about the scale of our
application
and the scale of our data platform we
got to make sure that
it can meet growing volumes of data
in production right now we're actually
dealing with over 10 terabytes of data
daily
and we issue numerous ad hoc queries
that
that try to get results from trillions
of events
finally we care quite a bit about
recency this whole idea of real time
and being able to explore events as
they're occurring
not hours after they've occurred
so to provide context with some of the
applications you can build
with the stack that we're going to
describe and to get a little bit of
understanding of how users can interact
with a data heavy application
i actually have a very simple demo and i
hope that the internet works
we were trying the wireless before and
it was really questionable
so this is a dashboard and
what this dashboard is visualizing is
edits as they're occurring on wikipedia
so
anytime anyone makes an edit on
wikipedia it basically generates
an event and this event contains a
timestamp of when the edit occurred
it contains different attributes about
the person or the individual doing the
edit
and also demo and also some information
about the page being edited
there's also some metrics involved in
any edit such as number of characters
added to a page
or the number of characters deleted so
on this dashboard you can see
the number of edits that have occurred
over the last week
there's about 1.8 million of them you
can see
a number of unique users that were doing
edits and the total number of characters
added or deleted here
and if we want to do a little bit deeper
exploration
we can do a filter on country united
states
and we can see you know these are
the top edited page in the united states
over the last week
so farewell my love which is apparently
a band is getting a lot of edits in the
us
we can do things like we can filter on a
particular
city such as
saint louis
okay and we can further explore this
wikipedia
data and we can see the voice uh
apparently it's pretty popular in st
louis
as is uh fast and furious characters it
was a pretty cool movie
so i'm on board you can do things like
you can compare
the top edited pages and you can zoom
into different time ranges
like over the last few hours you know
what are the what are the top
pages that are being edited
um and so on and so forth
okay cool so i'm really glad that
the internet held up because we made
these slides like five minutes for this
presentation thinking the internet might
not work
okay so uh in order to build an
application
like the one i just demoed and really
any time we're trying to build a data
stack we're trying to build a solution
that involves analytics on top of a lot
of data
the first solution the first technology
you might think about using
is hadoop and you know hadoop is a very
powerful tool
uh you can load all of your data into
hadoop and you can query it
and maybe you've solved all the problems
you wanted to solve with that data
is it really that simple well
it's true that you can do everything
with hoop you can do data ingestion
you can do data processing you can do
queries on top of hadoop
um and while mapreduce is a very great
general framework um it can handle
almost every
distributed computing problem that you
can think of uh
mapreduce is not particularly optimized
to do a lot of things very well
in particular mapreduce queries
mapreduce of your raw data can be very
very slow
and when you want interactive
exploration of data
what a lot of companies have realized
and what we realized a few years ago as
well
was that you oftentimes need to put
a query layer in front of hadoop and
um that query letter can really help
optimize the queries you're trying to
make
so our solution gets a little bit more
advanced
in that we introduce a dedicated query
layer to make queries faster
and we use hadoop for pre-processing and
storage
now there are a lot of different choices
in
a query layer and we generally recommend
that when you're choosing a query layer
you try and
pick a solution that's optimized for the
types of queries you're trying to make
so for us we are particularly concerned
with
business intelligence style queries and
these queries
might be things like we want to know how
much revenue was generated over time
broken down by some demographic or
in the advertising world this could be
the top publishers
based on clicks over the last month or
how many unique visitors visited some
site broken down by some user
demographic
so in these types of queries uh what
we're not doing
is we're not dumping an entire data set
nor
are we really querying for an individual
row what we really care about
is a filtered view of some set of data
and we're primarily concerned with
performing some sort of
aggregation
in order to answer some of these
questions uh there's different solutions
that we actually tried and i'm sure many
of you have tried as well
we started out with looking at
relational databases and within this
class of solutions you have
my you have postgres many others
what we found with trying to use
relational databases
was the scan speed over your data tended
to be quite slow
so we also looked at nosql key value
stores
uh within this class of data stores you
have solutions like hbase
and like cassandra can kind of be placed
here as well
and we're trying to do like business
intelligent style queries with a lot of
aggregates
with these nosql key value stores what
you often end up doing
is precomputing results so you try and
pre-compute out
every single qr every single query that
a user can make
and what we found was the pre
computation time
was getting to be really really
expensive
um we also actually evaluated a bunch of
commercial databases
for these types of queries you know you
have your verticas you have your
redshifts and
many many other solutions but we
tended to prefer open source we believe
that
no solution is going to exactly meet
your needs
and the customization and flexibility
you get with open source is actually
really powerful
so a few years ago we actually ended up
building our own data store
and that data store is called druid
druid was first open sourced in late
2012
since then it's seen a growing community
and we've seen contributors from many
different organizations
druid now runs in production at
companies you've probably heard of such
as
yahoo or netflix and many other startups
that you probably
haven't heard of druid is
primarily designed from the ground up
for low latency ingestion and
aggregation
so druid is highly optimized for the
types of queries that we were trying to
make
and why druid is particularly good for a
certain class of queries
is really in its architecture and i just
have some examples here
imagine we have a raw data set like the
one i have showing here
this could be a sample data set from
online advertising data
you might have a timestamp dimension you
might have a bunch of attributes
and you might have a couple of metrics
in here
and one of the first things that druid
does when it ingests data
is it tries to roll the data up and what
we
mean by roll up is instead of
storing every single raw event you try
and
do a group by over the attributes or
dimensions of the data set
you try and aggregate the metrics
involved with the raw data
and you truncate the timestamps so as
opposed to storing all the raw data
you store hourly truncated data
what it further does is it partitions
data
by time time is a bit of a special
dimension in druid right now
maybe one day it won't be but in this
example here
how druid shards data is basically
it creates an immutable block of data
for a certain range of time
and this block is called a druid segment
so here we have two segments for two
separate days of data
most of the data in druid is immutable
and
immutable data confers a lot of
advantages
for one you can get reconsistency for
free
when you're dealing with immutable data
and a druid's parallelism model is such
that you use
one thread to scan one immutable segment
so if you want to do more concurrent
reads you can just add more cores
and you can get more reads that way you
can also have multiple threads
scan the same underlying data so really
druid is a system
that's really really optimized for reads
we try and keep our segments such that
computation
or scans over a given segment usually
completes in an order of milliseconds
and what that allows for is pretty
efficient resource utilization
you keep your units of computation small
and you frequently yield resources
and that's actually pretty good in a
multi-tenant environment
and finally with druid's concept of
immutable segments
uh it's a pretty simple distribution and
replication model
when you want to load balance move data
around you just actually move blocks of
data around
and when you want to replicate data you
just replicate segments you just create
blocks
some more information druid is
fundamentally a column store
and the advantages of column stores
versus row stores for doing aggregation
for doing business intelligence style
queries
is pretty well documented you only scan
and load
whatever it is you need and with most
column stores there's a lot of different
compression algorithms
that you can introduce druid also
borrows a lot of ideas
from search infrastructure so there's
unique indexes that it builds
such as inverted indexes if you're not
familiar with inverted indexes
you don't have to worry too much the
idea is that druid builds a lot of
unique indexes
that make sure that when you issue a
query only exactly
the data that's pertaining to that query
is ever scanned
so it's pretty efficient about doing
reads
in the early days of druid the
architecture was
pretty simple a few years ago all you
could do with druid was basically
you would have your data your static set
of data in a distributed file system
somewhere
you would run a mapreduce job over that
data create the segment structure that
druid understands
and load it across a set of druid nodes
called historical nodes
and historical nodes are pretty simple
they know how to load data
drop data and scan data really quickly
in front of the historical nodes we have
another set of nodes called broker nodes
and broker nodes encapsulate query
scatter gather functionality
so when you send a query to a broker
node it knows what pieces of data live
where
it forwards the query down the
historical nodes compute their portion
of the answer in parallel
return results the broker node the
broker merges results and returns to the
caller
so we deployed into production a few
years ago
and what we gained with using druid was
we felt we had solved our query latency
problem
druid gave us arbitrary data exploration
and it gave us very fast queries
some benchmarks or some results from our
druid cluster as of a few months ago
um on data sets that are over 100
terabytes in size
the vast majority of our queries return
in an order of milliseconds
so we introduced druid but there were
still a bunch of problems
that were still remaining in the first
version of druid we had to load data
versus
in this mapreduce process and batch
loading data was very slow
we still didn't fully have this concept
of real time
we could not explore events as they were
occurring and if we were able to do that
there were a lot of features that we
could unlock such as alerts
we could do operational monitoring and
so forth
so to talk a little bit more about how
to build
a real-time data pipeline i'm actually
going to hand things off to jion
who's going to go into a little bit more
detail
hey uh cool i think the mic works
um so like feng jin said
we sort of in the early days realized
that would make sense is to separate
data processing and data storage from
data querying
and so the data querying system that we
ended up using was druid
and like fangshin said for data
processing in the early days we used
hadoop
mapreduce which worked but it had some
issues
uh so right so it looks sort of like
this hadoop for pre-processing and
storage and druid for queries
um the way that we did things back in
those days which was maybe
two years ago is our clients uploaded
data to s3
uh we're all running our service all
runs in the amazon cloud
um and we use hadoop and pig to clean it
up transform it and join it
and by joining it um i mean that our
data is mostly ad tech data so we have
impressions and clicks and we want to
correlate those to figure out things
like click through rate um
so after running those mapreduce jobs we
load the result into druid
and the typical turnaround time for that
whole process is
two to eight hours after the event
occurs and from that point it's
available for
the sort of arbitrary slice and dice
analytics changing was talking about
um what we started doing last year was
building a real-time version of this
pipeline
um so we decided to go
go back to what the bad platform
actually does and figure out how we can
make it real time
so there's there's three things that a
data pipeline does you have to acquire
raw data somehow
you have to process that data the
transforming and cleaning and joining
and you have to load the process data
into your query engine
which in our case is druid
um so we attack each of these
three things independently the first
thing
uh acquiring raw data we use kafka for
for those not familiar with kafka it's
an open source
product from linkedin
it's uh it's sort of a big message queue
in the sky
uh you have messages coming in messages
going out and it buffers them up for you
it's very high throughput it's got a
straightforward design which was the
the reason that we chose it over the
other things out there
and what we did was we put an http api
in front of it
so our customers can post the stuff over
the web
the architecture of a kafka system looks
something like this
you have kafka brokers sitting in the
middle you have producers on the left
which are things that generate events
and you have consumers on the right
which are things that process events
the nice thing about this is that the
producers and consumers don't have to
know about each other
the producers put things into kafka and
the consumers take things out
and if one of them is having issues then
as long as the kafka brokers in the
middle are working which they usually
are everything is fine
um the next thing to tackle was
processing events to
cleaning up transforming and joining so
for that we use storm
it's a stream processor it's also open
source it was originally developed at a
little startup called backtype and then
popularized at twitter it processes one
event at a time you set up these sort of
computation graphs where tuples come in
somewhere and then fly around and
eventually
fly out and
right so we want these storm topologies
which is what storm jobs are called to
do the same thing that our hadoop jobs
had done
so we look at what the doop jobs do they
they're mapreduce jobs they do three
things they load data from somewhere in
hadoop it's usually s3
or hdfs they map the
data which is sort of taking every event
and assigning a key and a value to it
and they reduce the events which is
taking
every thing every value with the same
key collecting it together and then
doing some sort of reduction on it which
in our case is
usually a join or an aggregation
load and map operations are pretty
streaming friendly
there's not really much to do with them
you can load one event at a time and map
one event at a time
but it's assigning a keen value to it
the reduce is the tricky part
the semantics of reduce and a batch job
are collecting all values with the same
key
which presents a challenge in a
streaming environment because you don't
necessarily
know when all things with the same key
have come in i mean the key might be
a uh in our case a impression id and we
may have an impression with that id and
a click with that id
and if no one ever clicks on the ad then
the click will never come in if someone
clicks on it in
20 minutes and it'll come in after 20
minutes
so what we do and what's fairly common
is to put a window on these operations
and so that means we first see the we
first see a key of some sort
uh we start a timer and collect things
with that same key
and um eventually that timer runs out
and whatever we've got by that point we
do the reduce on
um this works it's not
perfect but it works well enough for
most applications
um the last thing to do is load
uh process data into your query engine
so for us that was druid and like
fangshin said in the early days drug
architecture was
batch ingestion based so at some point
we had to make a streaming ingestion
system for druid
and what we did was we looked at what we
had druid has
a indexing system which can take data
and create data segments
it has a serving system the historical
nodes which can take data segments and
answer queries on them
and so we just sort of slam them
together and we have these things called
real-time indexers
that can build indexes and then as
they're building them allow queries to
occur on them
um the architecture looks something like
this when you put it together
the kafka producers aren't pictured but
they're there on the left
off screen data ends up in kafka brokers
storm workers pick it up do the joining
cleaning transforming
they push things to they push events to
druid real-time workers
which are building data segments and
also allowing queries on them
and then the druid real-time workers
periodically finalize their segments
which is converting them from a right
optimized form to a read optimized form
and hand them off to historical nodes
that's really important because like
feng jin said
the data segment format is optimized
really heavily for reads
but the real-time workers cannot
directly create that format they have to
create they have to use a write
optimized format and then convert it to
read optimized later
so while that's occurring uh the druid
query broker
is able to merge results from both the
historical cluster and the real-time
workers
so a typical druid cluster will have the
past uh
one to two hours of data in the
real-time nodes and all other data going
back potentially months or years in the
historical cluster
and so if you make a query for the past
24 hours then
one or two hours of data will come from
real time and the other
22 will come from the historical nodes
um so we end up adding this third row
which is uh the real time system that we
developed
um data comes into kafka then gets
processed by storm
and then we use druid for querying and
hadoop at this point is not really in
the picture anymore
so this is what we gained um we got some
cool stuff
we got the ability for druid quarries to
reflect new events within seconds
we don't have this two-day eight-hour
delay anymore the systems are fully
decoupled which is good this means
that if for some reason there's issues
in storm then we can still accept data
in kafka so
our customers are still able to post
data to us over the web and druid
queries still work the data becomes a
little more stale but we can still query
whatever was ingested up to that point
um there are brief processing delays
during maintenance
because we need to restart storm
topologies but during that time again
query performance and availability are
not affected
but unfortunately stream processing is
not perfect
the two biggest issues that we've faced
are that it's difficult to handle
corrections
of existing data and what i mean by that
is if you have some server that had some
issue and post the data very late
it may be difficult to reintegrate that
into the cluster or if you have some
data that
is bad in some way it needs to be fixed
it can be difficult to unload the
old data and load in new data
the other issue is that the windows for
the reduces
um may be too small for fully accurate
operations
one thing that we see pretty commonly in
our data pipelines is that if we
have a window of maybe 10 or 15 minutes
we can get over 95 percent of the data
joined up properly
but that remaining five percent um gets
lost because it may take someone an hour
to click on an ad
um and uh that last little bit is
it would be nice to have it um
so hadoop is actually good at these
things
hadoop can do very big windows all you
need to do is
load all the data into a big mapreduce
job and let it go and hadoop can handle
corrections resisting data all you have
to do is rerun the same hadoop job on
the older data set
so what we can do is we can bring back
hadoop
and actually use both a batch pipeline
and a real-time pipeline
this has been described by others and
there's has been called a land
architecture so this is
our open source implementation of
lambda architecture and the way it works
at least in our case
is that we automatically do batch
reprocessing for any data older than a
few hours
and that's mostly the main reason it's
automatic as opposed to
on demand is just because we always want
to redo things with larger join windows
so when the batch job runs those
segments replace real-time segments in
druid
that's a sort of a built-in druid
feature that that makes it easier to run
this sort of system
um and the druid query broker continues
to merge results from both systems
it can take segments from the real-time
nodes um
also segments handed off from real time
to historical and also segments created
by
the batch indexer and push historical
nodes and
integrate results from all three of
those in one unified query system
the architecture looks something like
this when you put it together
so you still have kafka storm and druid
on the top path
the real time path and that's operating
in real time over on time data
and then the bottom path the batch path
operates in our case some hours later
over all your data not just out of the
time time
and that may the data that gets
processed by that path replaces data
from the
top path
um so as promised this stuff is all
open source the the cornerstones of the
stack the four big pieces are druid
storm hadoop and kafka and they all have
websites and some of them have twitters
there's also glue between them which if
you've
had to integrate open source software
before you know that
sometimes those little red arrows are
kind of a pain to develop
so luckily that's those are also open
source
um the kafka storm link storm kafka was
a community contributed module that
recently became part of the main storm
distribution
um the storm the druid thing tranquility
is something that we open sourced a few
months ago
the kafka hadoop link kamu is something
that was open sourced
at linkedin the same place kafka came
from if you're using s3 instead of hdfs
there's something from pinterest that's
similar
and the hadoop to druid link is the
hadoop druid indexer which is just part
of druid
um right so you put all this together
what you get is queries answered quickly
on fresh data
kafka is providing fast and reliable
event transport
storm and hadoop are cleaning and
preparing data for druid
druid is handling queries and managing
merging and complexity in the serving
layer
and we call this the real-time analytics
data stack mostly because we like the
acronym
we wrote a blog post about it recently
as well which goes into a little bit
more detail
thanks guys
so the question is what's the backing
storage mechanism for druid
um it's pluggable uh the two most common
are s3 and hdfs and we use s3
um
so the question is streaming in old data
as opposed to doing
batch ingestion of all data currently
that's not possible the
the the way the druid currently supports
um ingesting of old data is uh wholesale
replaces of intervals
and so you say you know this hour get
rid of the data from this hour and
put this new data in for the hour and
it's an atomic operation
um yeah so what we we actually have a
couple of pipelines so
the thing was continuous sporadic
updates of old data
we have a couple pipelines that do have
that feature and usually what we do
is we do the first cut in real time
and druid has a parameter that says how
late it will accept data
so we set that to something reasonable
usually on the order of 10 15 minutes
we do the first cut in real time and
then
we run a series of batch jobs nightly
and so the the initial cut comes in real
time and then after that there's maybe
like a
few hour delay for things like updated
um
uh the question is um do we need to know
what kinds of queries are doing before
time to get efficient queries
uh no so um
druid doesn't do any precomputation and
doesn't do any
the indexes are not customizable or
really smart in any way you get the same
indexes on all columns no matter what
um it's
it gets its speed not from being really
smart about how it indexes things but it
gets its speed from just being really
really good at scanning stuff
um and also really good at filtering
um so uh
yeah is that your question cool
okay cool thanks